-Performing "BLACKOUT" from
their album "Glow On,"
give it up for Turnstile!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[With reverb] ♪ Blackout in
the middle of the light ♪
♪ And now I'm back down
with a feeling, and I collide ♪
♪ You know it won't be long
until the end ♪
♪ Let the spotlight shine
on me again ♪
♪♪
♪ Blackout in the middle
of your life ♪
♪ Just like a blackout
in the middle of the night ♪
♪ You know it won't be long
until the end ♪
♪ Let the spotlight
shine on me ♪
♪ And if it makes you
feel alive ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Well, then I'm happy
I provide ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ And when you see me
on the floor ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ It's just a part of my... ♪
♪♪
♪ Show ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ And if it makes you feel
alive ♪
-♪ Ooh♪
-♪ Well, then I'm happy
I provide ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ And when you see me
on the floor ♪
- Ooh ♪
-♪ It's just a part
of my show ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ It's just a part of my show ♪
♪♪
♪ It's just a part of my... ♪
[ Drum solo ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]